Well, it's been a week of gloating. Some very emphatic gloating and I-told-you-sos, after Robert Mueller delivered his report saying that he could not establish collusion between the president and the Russians. As you've probably seen, the president and his supporters have been saying that's right. No conspiracy with Russia.
这一周充满了幸灾乐祸。在罗伯特·穆勒提交报告称无法证实总统与俄罗斯人之间存在勾结后，出现了一些非常强烈的幸灾乐祸和“我早告诉过你”的声音。正如你可能已经看到的那样，总统及其支持者一直表示事实确实如此。没有与俄罗斯串通。
In fact, the real conspiracy is one where the Democrats and the media hyped this Russian stuff for two years. They're gleefully circulating videos of people like this guy--
事实上，真正的阴谋是民主党人和媒体两年来一直在炒作这些俄罗斯相关的事情。他们兴高采烈地传播着像这家伙这样的人的视频——
You know, you have to take seriously the possibility that--
你知道，你必须认真对待这种可能性，即——
--New York Magazine writer Jonathan Chait. He went onto MSNBC last year to connect the dots about whether the president has basically been a secret Russian operative all the way back since 1987.
——《纽约杂志》的撰稿人乔纳森·查特。去年他上了MSNBC节目，试图理清思路，探讨总统是否从1987年起就基本上是一名俄罗斯的秘密特工。
That is probably not true. But it might be that 1987 is when he went to Moscow. And he's feted by the Russians and tours Moscow. And then he comes back. Then he starts talking about running for president for the first time. And then he starts talking for the first time about how our allies are a bunch of freeloaders, and we should kick them to the curb.
这很可能不是真的。但1987年确实是他去莫斯科的时候。他受到俄罗斯人的款待，游览了莫斯科。然后他回来了。接着他第一次谈到要竞选总统。然后他第一次开始谈论我们的盟友是一群吃白饭的人，我们应该把他们踢开。
It's more or less a Fox News, Republican Party talking point now that the fact that there even was a Mueller investigation, the fact that it even occurred, was a result of a deep-state, media-led, Obama-Hillary-FBI conspiracy. Here's how President Trump described it this week to Sean Hannity.
现在，福克斯新闻和共和党的论调多多少少已经变成：穆勒调查本身的存在、调查这件事本身，就是深层政府、媒体主导的奥巴马-希拉里-FBI阴谋的结果。以下是特朗普总统本周向肖恩·汉尼提描述此事的说法。
You look at, how did this start? How did it start? You had dirty cops. You had people that are bad FBI folks. I know so many. They're incredible people. But at the top, they were not clean, to put it mildly.
你看看，这事是怎么开始的？是怎么开始的？你有肮脏的警察。你有坏的FBI成员。我认识很多人。他们是不可思议的人。但在高层，往好里说，他们并不干净。
And then the money that was spent-- the millions and millions on the phony dossier, and paid for by Hillary Clinton, and paid for by the Democrats at the DNC-- it's hard to believe. If you wrote this as a novel, nobody would buy it. It would be a failure, because it would be too unbelievable.
还有投入的钱——在虚假档案上花费的数百万美元，由希拉里·克林顿支付，由民主党全国委员会的民主党人支付——这很难相信。如果你把这个写成小说，没人会买。它会是一次失败，因为它太不可信了。
Of course, it's no surprise that the president has spun the Mueller report into a conspiracy theory of his own, because he's peddled lots of conspiracy theories, from the idea that George Soros is funding the caravans, all the way back to birtherism. Joe Uscinski, a professor at the University of Miami who studies conspiracy theories and the people who believe them, says, this is actually an unusual thing about today.
当然，总统把穆勒报告编造成他自己的阴谋论并不令人惊讶，因为他兜售过很多阴谋论，从乔治·索罗斯资助移民大篷车，一直到早期的出生地阴谋论。迈阿密大学研究阴谋论及其信奉者的教授乔·乌辛斯基说，这实际上是当今时代一件不寻常的事情。
It used to be people with no power in this country who were the ones pushing conspiracy theories. Now it's the President of the United States doing it all the time. Uscinski says that from the start, it seems like Donald Trump identified conspiracy-minded voters as a possible constituency.
过去，在这个国家推动阴谋论的都是没有权力的人。现在却是美国总统一直在做这件事。乌辛斯基说，从一开始，唐纳德·特朗普似乎就认定了那些阴谋论心态的选民是一个潜在的选民群体。
So when he got into the Republican primary, there was 25 other candidates vying for Republican votes. He went after the underserved market of Republicans, which were conspiracy-minded Republicans. But he keeps them motivated. And he's got to keep going with this. He's dancing with the one who brought him to the prom.
所以当他参加共和党初选时，有25名候选人在争夺共和党的选票。他瞄准了未被充分服务的共和党人市场，也就是那些有阴谋论心态的共和党人。但他保持了他们的积极性。他必须继续这样做。他得对他最初的盟友负责。
In fact, one of my coworkers, Zoe Chace, went to a couple of Trump rallies this fall in Chattanooga, Tennessee and Fort Wayne, Indiana. And she found lots of people who believed in the deep state and in other conspiracies. Zoe?
事实上，我的同事佐伊·蔡斯今年秋天去了田纳西州查塔努加和印第安纳州韦恩堡的几场特朗普集会。她发现很多人相信深层政府和其他阴谋论。佐伊？
Hi, IRA.
你好，艾拉。
So?
那么？
So basically, I'd ask people a general and vague question, like, do you trust the government? And then almost everyone I talked to, all these conspiracy theories would come spilling out, like about George Soros.
基本上，我会问人们一个笼统而模糊的问题，比如，你信任政府吗？然后我交谈过的几乎每个人，所有这些阴谋论就会倾泻而出，比如关于乔治·索罗斯。
--a Wizard of Oz behind the curtain, you know? People like that, they're behind the scenes, pushing this agenda.
——幕后的绿野仙踪，你知道吗？像那样的人，他们在幕后推动这个议程。
The president tweeted this theory that Soros pays protesters. There's no evidence of that.
总统在推特上发布了索罗斯支付抗议者费用的理论。没有任何证据支持这一点。
Absolutely. You can go on the website, and he'll pay you $17. I wanted to ask these people holding signs, where do they get their check? All these people, they're getting paid. What if-- what if they're getting paid?
当然。你可以上那个网站，他会付给你17美元。我想问那些举着牌子的人，他们的支票是从哪里来的？所有这些人，他们都是受雇的。如果——如果他们是拿钱办事的呢？
Old classics came up, like the Clintons are serial murderers.
旧的经典阴谋论出现了，比如克林顿夫妇是连环杀手。
And now, this may be conspiracy theorist type stuff. But how many bodyguards that Clinton had in Arkansas are still alive? Vince Foster.
现在，这可能属于阴谋论类型的东西。但是克林顿在阿肯色州有多少保镖还活着？文斯·福斯特。
Vince Foster?
文斯·福斯特？
Supposed to have been killed in the park.
据说是被杀于公园里。
I mean, he committed suicide. But you don't think so?
我的意思是，他是自杀的。但你不这么认为？
Well, I don't think he did, no.
嗯，我不认为他是自杀的，不。
Pizzagate came up.
“披萨门”出现了。
I don't believe there's, like, a basement in comet Ping Pong. But I do believe that there was a hacker that actually hacked into the system. And I think that the shooter going in was a false flag, because he shot one bullet right through the hard drive, destroying the evidence, so to speak. So I think--
我不相信“彗星乒乓”餐厅里有地下室什么的。但我确实相信有一个黑客真的入侵了系统。而且我认为那个闯入的枪手是一个“虚假旗帜”行动，因为他对着硬盘开了一枪，毁掉了证据，可以这么说。所以我认为——
I got this book recommendation that made a big impression on me from Paula. She and her partner, Steve, drove three hours from Pigeon Forge, Tennessee.
我从保拉那里得到了这个对我印象深刻的书籍推荐。她和她的伴侣史蒂夫从田纳西州的鸽子谷开了三个小时的车过来。
What's the name of that book?
那本书叫什么名字？
Oh, I can't remember.
哦，我不记得了。
Baby, look for it on my--
宝贝，在我的……上查一下。
It's an older book.
那是一本旧书。
--Amazon. It's an old, old book. But it's about how they've been trying to do this for many years in America.
——亚马逊。那是一本非常非常旧的书。但它是关于他们多年来在美国一直试图做这件事。
Yeah, since the middle 1800s.
是的，从19世纪中期开始。
Yes. They've been--
是的。他们一直——
Who's they, though?
不过，他们是谁？
The Illuminati, whatever you want to call them-- the World Order.
光明会，随你怎么称呼他们——世界秩序。
The World Order?
世界秩序？
Basically, the idea that a cabal of rich guys is trying to take over the world and create one world government-- like one currency, one army, no national borders.
基本上，这是一个阴谋集团的想法，即一群富人正试图接管世界并建立一个世界政府——比如统一货币、统一军队、没有国界。
And these rich guys-- are these Jews, not to name a specific ethnic group?
这些富人——这些人是犹太人吗，不是特指某个民族？
Not necessarily. It's not necessarily the Jews. This is an old theory. Its roots are totally anti-Semitic. But to be honest, the people I talked to, I asked them about that. It just seemed like it wasn't about Jews anymore. It was just elites.
不一定。不一定是犹太人。这是一个古老的理论。它的根源完全是反犹主义的。但老实说，我交谈过的人，我问过他们这个问题。看起来这已经不再是关于犹太人的了。只是关于精英阶层。
OK, then.
好吧，那就这样。
Eventually, Paula finds the name of the book. It's The Unseen Hand,
最终，保拉找到了那本书的名字。是《看不见的手》。
There you go. You read that, girl. And I haven't read all of it. But I have a friend that's read it from front to back. But it's like really well read in it. And we talked about the Illuminati and all of these so-called higher-ups that think that they are over all of us. I got news for them--
这就对了。你去读读看，姑娘。我还没读完。但我有个朋友从头到尾读过它。他读得非常认真。我们讨论了光明会和所有那些认为他们凌驾于我们之上的所谓高层人士。我给他们带去了一个消息——
Did you read the book?
你读过那本书吗？
I tried. It's really hard to follow the book. I got through like 100 pages. I did talk to their friend who's read the whole thing, Jim. And his experience illustrates that thing the professor, Uscinski, said at the beginning of this about how Donald Trump mobilized conspiracy theorists during the campaign.
我试过了。那本书真的很难读懂。我看了大概100页。我确实和读完它的朋友吉姆谈过。他的经历说明了教授乌辛斯基在节目开头提到的关于唐纳德·特朗普如何在竞选期间动员阴谋论者的问题。
Hm.
嗯。
Like, take Jim. He hadn't voted for a while before 2016, because he believed both parties were basically working together for a secret cabal of elites.
比如，拿吉姆来说。在2016年之前，他有一段时间没有投票，因为他相信两党基本上都在为一个秘密的精英集团共同工作。
So he believed this conspiracy.
所以他相信这个阴谋。
Yeah, the New World Order-- like, just rich guys, the Bilderberg group, George Soros, the Bush dynasty, the Clinton dynasty-- like, that they were all--
是的，世界新秩序——就像只是一些富人、彼尔德伯格集团、乔治·索罗斯、布什王朝、克林顿王朝——就像他们都在——
All working together?
都在一起工作？
--to push this one world government, New World Order agenda in secret.
——在幕后推动这个世界政府、世界新秩序的议程。
OK.
好吧。
And Jim believes Donald Trump ran for president in order to stop them.
吉姆相信唐纳德·特朗普竞选总统是为了阻止他们。
I didn't have to read between the lines of what he was saying. He was openly saying, I'm not a globalist. I'm America first. And see?
我不需要去解读他话里的潜台词。他公开说，我不是全球主义者。我是“美国优先”。看到了吗？
Unless you know a lot of the stuff I know, most-- a lot of what he said would just go, pshew. And I knew he knew. I knew he knew about what he said. He knew who they were and what they were up to.
除非你知道很多我知道的事情，否则——他说的很多话你只会一听而过。而我知道他懂。我知道他明白他说的话。他知道他们是谁，他们想干什么。
Talking to Jim, it was like seeing Trump all new.
与吉姆交谈，就像以全新的眼光看特朗普。
Huh.
哈。
Like, seeing him through Jim's eyes, seriously, everything kind of lined up for me.
就像通过吉姆的眼睛看他，说真的，一切对我来说都对上了。
What do you mean?
这是什么意思？
So no borders-- Trump wants to build a border wall, right? Because the New World Order wants to erase all the borders. Trump wants to blow up all the trade deals. Like, trade deals lead to, you know, one world currency.
所以没有国界——特朗普想要建立边界墙，对吧？因为世界新秩序想要抹除所有的边界。特朗普想要炸毁所有的贸易协定。比如，贸易协定会导致，你知道，统一货币。
Right. They're breaking down trade borders between nations.
对。他们正在打破国家之间的贸易壁垒。
Yes it's another kind of erasing-the-barriers thing. Trump wants to blow up NATO. You can kind of think of that as one world army with these different countries coming together.
是的，这是另一种抹除壁垒的东西。特朗普想要炸毁北约。你可以把它想象成世界军队，让这些不同的国家联合在一起。
The NATO military, OK.
北约军队，好的。
Right, the NATO alliance. Trump kind of alienates our allies, doesn't like to talk to Europe, because Europe-- that's the European Union. The European Union is the first step towards a global union, one big state.
对，北约联盟。特朗普有点疏远我们的盟友，不喜欢和欧洲交谈，因为欧洲——那是欧盟。欧盟是通往全球联盟、统一大国的第一步。
Oh, where all-- right, we're all one big country.
哦，那是——对，我们都是一个大国家。
Yeah, one world government. And if you listen to Trump, it does sound like he believes in a cabal of elites behind the scenes, like Soros; obviously, Hillary Clinton; lately, the FBI.
是的，世界政府。如果你听特朗普的话，听起来他确实相信幕后存在一个精英阴谋集团，比如索罗斯；显然，希拉里·克林顿；最近，FBI。
Right.
对。
All the dots line up so neatly if you just think of them as part of Trump's battle against the New World Order.
如果你仅仅把它们视为特朗普对抗世界新秩序战斗的一部分，所有的点就都连起来了。
And do you think Jim is right that the president sees it this way?
你认为吉姆认为总统是以这种方式看待事情是对的吗？
No. But you can see how Jim would draw these conclusions. It makes sense.
不。但你可以看出吉姆是怎么得出这些结论的。这说得通。
Well, today on our program, in this moment, when conspiracy theories seem to be right in the center of mainstream political everything-- like, for years, there was this idea that the president conspired with the Russians. Now, there's this idea that the Democrats conspired to create a phony investigation. When are we supposed to be connecting the dots? When are we not supposed to be connecting the dots?
好了，今天在我们的节目中，在这一刻，当阴谋论似乎处于主流政治的一切核心时——就像多年来一直有这种观点，认为总统与俄罗斯人串通。现在，有这种观点认为民主党人串通制造了一场虚假的调查。我们什么时候应该连接这些点？什么时候又不应该连接这些点？
Because, friends, there are a lot of dots. And they are so close together. And we want to connect them, because we want something to explain the world that we're in.
因为，朋友们，有很多点。它们靠得太近了。我们想把它们连起来，因为我们想要某种东西来解释我们所处的世界。
Today on our program, we have stories of people struggling with whether they should be connecting the dots or not, and as you might expect, coming to very different conclusions. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们要讲一些人们在纠结是否应该连接这些点的故事，正如你所预料的，他们得出了非常不同的结论。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Show-Me State of Mind. So many people who believe in conspiracy theories, you know they're talking about secretive groups that are basically far away-- rich and powerful people they're never going to run into. But what about when the conspiracy looks like it's happening all around you-- like, has an impact on your actual city, on your actual neighborhood? And you're worried that you could be its next victim. New Yorker writer Jelani Cobb heard about a conspiracy theory that is more along those lines.
第一幕，“密苏里州的心态”。许多相信阴谋论的人，你知道，他们谈论的是基本上遥不可及的秘密团体——他们永远不会遇到的富有和有权势的人。但是，当阴谋看起来就在你身边发生时呢——比如，对你所在的城市、你的社区产生影响？你担心自己可能成为下一个受害者。《纽约客》撰稿人杰拉尼·科布听说了一个更符合这种情况的阴谋论。
It's been more than four years now since Michael Brown was shot by a police officer in Ferguson, Missouri, outside St. Louis. You probably know the basic facts of the case. He was 18, black, unarmed. The officer who shot him, Darren Wilson, is white.
距离迈克尔·布朗在密苏里州弗格森（圣路易斯郊外）被警察枪杀已经过去了四年多了。你可能了解这个案件的基本事实。他18岁，黑人，手无寸铁。开枪的警察达伦·威尔逊是白人。
Of course, the shooting and a grand jury's decision not to indict Officer Wilson led to waves of chaotic protests in Ferguson-- tear gas, arrests, fires, looting. It was the first time you heard the chant, hands up, don't shoot. But here's something you might not know.
当然，枪击事件和大陪审团决定不起诉威尔逊警官导致弗格森爆发了混乱的抗议浪潮——催泪瓦斯、逮捕、火灾、抢劫。那是你第一次听到“举起手，别开枪”的口号。但这里有一些你可能不知道的事情。
In the five years since Michael Brown's death, about a half dozen people connected to the shooting and its aftermath have themselves turned up dead, including high-profile protesters and activists. And in at least a few cases, the circumstances under which they've died have been questionable, if not eerie, which has led to the belief that those deaths are part of a larger, coordinated effort-- in short, a conspiracy.
在迈克尔·布朗去世后的五年里，大约有六个与枪击事件及其后果有关的人自己离奇死亡，包括高调的抗议者和活动家。至少在几个案例中，他们死亡的环境令人质疑，甚至令人毛骨悚然，这导致人们认为这些死亡是一项更大、更协调的努力的一部分——简而言之，一个阴谋。
I had already visited Ferguson about a half dozen times, met a lot of people, and wrote several articles. But that was three years ago. I decided to go back and ask some of them whether they believed in the conspiracy. I was interested in who did, and who didn't, and why.
我已经去过弗格森大约六次了，见过很多人，写了几篇文章。但那是三年前的事了。我决定回去问问他们中有些人是否相信这个阴谋。我感兴趣的是谁相信，谁不相信，以及原因。
One place that I spent a lot of time was Cathy's Kitchen-- sort of a hub for reporters, as it was only about 100 feet from the police department and a few miles down the road from where the shooting happened. One of the co-owners, Jerome Jenkins, was wiping down the counter when I walked in.
我花了很多时间的一个地方是凯西厨房——算是记者的中心，因为它离警察局只有大约100英尺，离枪击发生的地方只有几英里远。当我走进去时，共同所有者之一杰罗姆·詹金斯正在擦柜台。
Hey, how you been?
嘿，你怎么样？
How you doing? How you doing?
你好吗？你好吗？
You been doing good?
你一直都好吗？
Yeah, just I didn't know if you were gonna remember me.
是的，只是我不知道你是否还会记得我。
Of course. How would I forget?
当然。我怎么会忘记？
You came at a never-forgetful time in our lives, Jerome said.
你来到了我们生命中一个永远无法忘记的时刻，杰罗姆说。
--a never-forgetful time in our life.
——我们生命中一个永远无法忘记的时刻。
Yeah, that's true.
是的，那确实。
Just then, his wife, the Cathy in Cathy's Kitchen, came over.
就在这时，他的妻子，凯西厨房里的凯西，走了过来。
There's Miss Cathy.
凯西小姐来了。
How are you doing?
你好吗？
How you doing?
How are you doing?
你好吗？
Good to see you. How you been?
很高兴见到你。你一直怎么样？
Good to see you. Good, good.
很高兴见到你。好，好。
Pleasure, pleasure. How are you?
荣幸，荣幸。你好吗？
The place has a vintage feel-- a long bar with leather and chrome stools and a checkerboard tile pattern on the floor. It didn't surprise me when Jerome said that customers sometimes discuss whether they think the deaths are connected. He suspects they are.
这个地方有一种复古的感觉——一个带有皮革和铬合金凳子的长吧台，地板上有方格瓷砖图案。当杰罗姆说顾客有时会讨论他们是否认为这些死亡事件有关联时，我并不感到惊讶。他怀疑是有关系的。
It's hard to say it's a coincidence. And it doesn't seem like there's a big investigation into it. At this point, to me, it seems like, you know, raised eyebrows. And--
很难说这是一种巧合。而且看起来并没有对它进行大规模的调查。在这一点上，对我来说，看起来像是，你知道，扬起眉毛。而且——
Raised eyebrows. Almost all the people we talked to who gave credence to the conspiracy used that phrase. It's perfect, because it doesn't commit you to tinfoil-hat-level conspiracy. But it does point you in the direction of something being afoot.
扬起眉毛。几乎所有我们交谈过、对阴谋论表示认同的人都使用了这个短语。这很完美，因为它不会让你陷入锡箔帽级别的阴谋论。但它确实让你觉得有什么事情正在发生。
You got a suicide. You got a burning in a car. You got a homicide. You have all these strange things coming from one thing that all these people have in common, you know? You know, they're all people that are activists, that are standing up, you know, trying to say, hey, we want to make this better. We want this. And they all are dying in some weird form.
你有自杀。你有在车里烧死。你有谋杀。你有所有这些奇怪的事情出自同一件事，而这些人都有共同点，你知道吗？你知道，他们都是活动家，他们站出来，你知道，试图说，嘿，我们想让这变得更好。我们想要这个。而且他们都以某种奇怪的形式死去。
Just doesn't add up.
这根本说不通。
To me--
对我来说——
But do you think, is it something that's coordinated? Is it the fact that we have, like, homicide rates that are terrible in many of the cities? Like, how do we distinguish between those two?
但你认为，这是否是协调一致的？这是否是因为我们有很多城市有着可怕的谋杀率？比如，我们如何区分这两者？
I understand our community. I understand our suicide, homicide. I understand those rates. But let's look at it a different way. If five African-Americans die in the NBA, and they all have one thing in common, they all play for the Lakers, it would be an investigation. It would be, because you had this one thing in common, we would all go, it's too many.
我了解我们的社区。我了解我们的自杀、谋杀。我了解那些比率。但让我们换一种方式来看。如果五个非裔美国人在NBA死亡，并且他们都有一个共同点，他们都为湖人队打球，那就会有调查。那会有的，因为你有这个共同点，我们都会说，这太多了。
And these are people-- don't live that far from each other. That's a large number. So that's what makes it enter into the world of--
而且这些人——住得离彼此并不远。那是一个很大的数字。所以这就是让它进入那个世界的原因——
It raises an eyebrow, uh-huh.
这引起了怀疑，嗯哼。
It raises an eyebrow, you know?
这引起了怀疑，你知道吗？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Here are the six deaths that raise suspicions in and around Ferguson. In September of 2016, Darren Seals, a very visible activist in Ferguson, was found shot in the head inside a burning vehicle. He was 29, outspoken, and had mentioned he was being harassed by police in the months before his death.
以下是弗格森及其周边地区引起怀疑的六起死亡事件。2016年9月，弗格森的一位非常引人注目的活动家达伦·西尔斯被发现头部中弹，死在一辆燃烧的车内。他29岁，直言不讳，曾提到他在去世前几个月受到警察的骚扰。
Pictures from the murder scene went up on Twitter shortly afterward, apparently showing that after police investigated, there were still bullet casings littering the parking lot. The suggestion was that police were incompetent and possibly even complicit in Seals' death.
谋杀现场的照片在不久后上传到推特上，显然显示警察调查后，停车场里仍然散落着弹壳。暗示警察无能，甚至可能与西尔斯的死有关。
One person replied, "You better believe those KKKops were involved." The word "KKKops" is spelled with three Ks. A spokesman for the St. Louis County Police Department says all evidence pertinent to the case was processed.
有人回复说，“你最好相信那些三K党警察参与了。”单词“KKKops”拼写有三个K。圣路易斯县警察局的一位发言人表示，所有与该案相关的证据都已处理。
Two years earlier, Deandre Joshua, 20 years old, was reportedly found the same way, inside a burnt-out vehicle, with a gunshot wound to the head. Joshua was friends with someone who'd witnessed Michael Brown's shooting. And his death is also often linked to the death of Shawn Gray, a 23-year-old who disappeared that same week and was later found drowned in a branch of the Mississippi River.
两年前，20岁的迪安德·约书亚据报道也是以同样的方式被发现，在一辆烧毁的车内，头部有枪伤。约书亚是迈克尔·布朗枪击案目击者的朋友。他的死也常与肖恩·格雷的死联系在一起，肖恩·格雷是一名23岁的年轻人，在那一周失踪，后来被发现淹死在密西西比河的一条支流中。
The rumor was that they'd both been killed for testifying before the grand jury in Michael Brown's case. But the list of grand jury witnesses has never been released. And with both men, their friends and family insist that they had nothing to do with the case. The county prosecutor confirmed that Joshua had not been a witness.
传言说他们两人都是因为在迈克尔·布朗案的大陪审团面前作证而被杀。但大陪审团的证人名单从未公布。对于这两个人，他们的朋友和家人都坚称他们与此案无关。县检察官证实约书亚不是证人。
And then there's Edward Crawford, possibly the most visible person associated with the protests. You may have seen a famous photo of him wearing an American flag t-shirt and hurling a tear gas canister back in the direction of police. In 2017, he died from a gunshot wound while sitting in a vehicle with two women, one of whom was his sister. Police concluded it was a suicide. Crawford's father thinks it was an accident. Crawford was 27.
还有爱德华·克劳福德，他可能是与抗议活动有关的最引人注目的人。你可能见过他穿着美国国旗T恤、把催泪瓦斯罐投向警察方向的一张著名照片。2017年，他在和两个女人（其中一个是他的姐姐）坐在车里时死于枪伤。警方认定为自杀。克劳福德的父亲认为这是一起意外。克劳福德当时27岁。
The most recent death that's gotten a lot of attention is that of Danye Jones. Last year, Jones was found hanging from a tree in his backyard. He was 24. Police have investigated Jones' death as a suicide, too. But Danye's mother, Melissa McKinnies, had been prominent in organizing the protests. She believes he was lynched to send her a message.
最近引起广泛关注的死亡事件是丹耶·琼斯的死亡。去年，琼斯被发现吊在他家后院的树上。他24岁。警方也将琼斯的死亡作为自杀进行了调查。但丹耶的母亲梅丽莎·麦金尼斯在组织抗议活动中一直很突出。她认为他被私刑处死是为了给她传达信息。
She says she found his packed bag nearby, suggesting he was going somewhere with someone he trusted. Also, she said the sheet he was hanging from didn't come from the house. And he didn't know how to tie those particular knots.
她说她在附近发现了他的包裹，暗示他正和某个他信任的人一起去某个地方。此外，她说他悬挂的床单不是来自家里的。而且他不知道如何打那些特定的结。
The deaths have become something of a set piece, not simply in the minds of people who live in the area, but in the media as well. You'll see headlines like "Ferguson, Missouri Activists Are Dying, And It's Time to Ask Questions" and "Are Ferguson Protesters Being Killed?"
这些死亡事件已经成为一种定型化的东西，不仅在当地居民的心中，在媒体中也是如此。你会看到像“弗格森，密苏里州的活动家正在死亡，是时候问问题了”和“弗格森抗议者正在被杀吗？”这样的标题。
People in those articles and in our interviews and online have pondered all kinds of possible culprits, from white supremacists, to local and federal law enforcement, to armed militia members who were seen standing on the tops of buildings during the protests. The articles didn't come to any conclusions or investigate the deaths. And you're not going to hear me do that either.
那些文章和我们的采访以及在线上的人们思考了各种可能的罪魁祸首，从白人至上主义者，到当地和联邦执法部门，再到抗议期间被看到站在建筑物顶部的武装民兵成员。这些文章没有得出任何结论，也没有对死亡事件进行调查。你也不会听到我这么做。
But I was interested in the narrative that had attached itself to those deaths and what it could tell me about how people were processing what was happening around them. I talked with five people who believed the conspiracy to some degree, including Jerome and Cathy Jenkins at the restaurant. And again, nobody I talked to went full "NASA faked the moon landing" conspiratorial.
但我感兴趣的是那些死亡事件所附带的叙事，以及它能告诉我人们是如何处理他们周围正在发生的事情的。我采访了五位在某种程度上相信阴谋论的人，包括餐厅的杰罗姆和凯西·詹金斯。再次强调，我交谈过的任何人都没有完全陷入“美国宇航局伪造登月”那种阴谋论。
But what you did get were clusters of suspicion, brushfires of doubt about the official narratives of what was happening around them. The conspiracy wasn't present in the words they spoke. It was tucked into the ellipses between them.
但你得到的是怀疑的集群，是对他们周围正在发生的官方叙事的怀疑之火。阴谋并没有出现在他们说的话中。它隐藏在他们话语之间的省略号里。
The sixth thing that tends to come up in these discussions is Bassem Masri. He was a Palestinian-American activist and close to many of the organizers in Ferguson. He died of an apparent heart attack aboard a city bus.
在这些讨论中倾向于出现的第六件事是巴塞姆·马斯里。他是一位巴勒斯坦裔美国活动家，与弗格森的许多组织者关系密切。他死于公共汽车上的一场突发心脏病。
A 31 year old dying of a heart attack is the kind of thing that might raise suspicions, and yes, eyebrows, even outside the context of other people dying in quick succession, except we got a copy of the medical examiner's report. And while, yes, Masri was in cardiac arrest when he got to the hospital, the official cause of death was a fentanyl overdose. He had struggled with heroin addiction prior to this and was open about it.
一个31岁的人死于心脏病，这种事情可能会引起怀疑，是的，会扬起眉毛，即使在其他人接连死亡的背景之外也是如此，除非我们收到了法医报告。虽然，是的，马斯里到医院时确实心脏骤停，但官方的死亡原因是芬太尼过量。他之前曾与海洛因成瘾作斗争，并且对此很坦率。
And there are other ways in which the conspiracy narrative doesn't hold up. St. Louis proper has one of the most alarming homicide rates in the country. In 2017, it was the most alarming, having the highest murder rate, according to an analysis of FBI data. By comparison, Chicago was number nine. So lots of people get shot in St. Louis.
而且阴谋叙事站不住脚还有其他方式。圣路易斯市本身的谋杀率是全国最令人担忧的之一。根据对FBI数据的分析，2017年它甚至是最令人担忧的，谋杀率最高。相比之下，芝加哥排名第九。所以圣路易斯很多人被枪杀。
Also, neither Deandre Joshua nor Shawn Gray was an activist. And even if they did testify before the grand jury, Joshua and Gray were both found dead after the decision not to indict Officer Wilson, meaning they'd have been killed for testimony that had not even convinced a grand jury to issue an indictment
此外，迪安德·约书亚和肖恩·格雷都不是活动家。即使他们确实在大陪审团面前作证，约书亚和格雷都是在决定不起诉威尔逊警官后被发现死亡的，这意味着他们因为作证被杀，而这些作证甚至没能说服大陪审团起诉。
I talked about all of this with Ashley Yates, a prominent figure in the Ferguson protests. Of all the people I spoke with for this story, she most epitomized the equivocal belief in the idea of a conspiracy, parsing the difference between what is provable and what is likely.
我与弗格森抗议活动中的知名人物阿什利·耶茨谈到了所有这些。在我为这个故事采访的所有人中，她最典型地代表了对阴谋概念的模棱两可的信念，分析了什么是可证明的和什么是可能的之间的区别。
Can I say that right now, in this moment, there is a conspiracy against activists? No, because again, I don't have the hard, concrete evidence. Can I say that it is likely? When I take into account my experiences, the experiences of people around me and those before, absolutely.
我能说现在，在这一刻，有一个针对活动家的阴谋吗？不能，因为再次强调，我没有确凿的证据。我能说这很可能吗？当我考虑到我的经历、我周围人的经历以及之前人们的经历时，绝对是。
Even at the same time, I wonder if it's possible, with Mr. Joshua and Mr. Gray, if they're-- it's possible, do you think that there really is a conspiracy, but they're just not part of it?
与此同时，我想知道是否有可能，对于约书亚先生和格雷先生，如果他们是——你认为这是否可能，真的有一个阴谋，但他们只是不属于它？
I mean, anything's possible. Again, I don't have-- you know, I don't have thorough investigations. I don't have the answers. I didn't murder them. I wasn't there, you know?
我的意思是，任何事情都是可能的。再次，我没有——你知道，我没有详尽的调查。我没有答案。不是我杀了他们。我当时不在场，你知道吗？
So only the people that were there can tell us completely what happened. So of course, it's possible that there is a conspiracy and that they're not a part. It's possible that there isn't a conspiracy, and all of these deaths are unrelated. Like, again, I hold all possibilities. And I try to go towards the most likely one.
所以只有在场的人才能完全告诉我们发生了什么。所以当然，有可能存在阴谋，而他们不是一部分。有可能不存在阴谋，所有这些死亡都是无关的。就像，再次强调，我保留所有可能性。我试图走向最可能的一个。
Mm-hm.
嗯哼。
But I'd say that to-- to say that there is something normal about a person being shot and found in a burned-out car one time, let alone two, three times-- you know, I don't want to accept that and say that that's just a likely outcome for anybody.
但我会说，要说一个人被枪杀并发现死在烧毁的车里是正常的，更不用说两次、三次了——你知道，我不想接受并说这对任何人来说都只是一个可能的结果。
And I should say, technically, it wasn't the outcome for Deandre Joshua. I only learned this after talking to Ashley and the others. But according to the St. Louis County Medical Examiner's Office, Joshua was not found in a burned-out car the way everyone thinks. His body was partly burned, but the car was not.
我应该说，技术上讲，这并不是迪安德·约书亚的下场。我只是在与阿什利和其他人交谈后才了解到这一点。但根据圣路易斯县法医办公室的说法，约书亚并不是像每个人认为的那样被发现死在烧毁的车里。他的身体部分烧焦，但车并没有。
This may sound like a small point, except the supposed similarity between Darren Seals' death and Deandre Joshua's death is a load-bearing pillar in the structure of the conspiracy. And it wasn't just spread word of mouth. It's been widely reported in the media as fact. Though, of course, even though it's not true, the deaths could still be connected.
这听起来可能是一个小细节，除了达伦·西尔斯的死和迪安德·约书亚的死之间所谓的相似之处是阴谋结构中的一根承重柱。而且它不仅仅是口头传播。它在媒体中被广泛报道为事实。尽管，当然，即使它不是真的，这些死亡仍然可能是有联系的。
Do you have ideas about who might be responsible for the-- for these deaths?
你对谁可能对这些死亡负责有什么想法吗？
Other than, like, the government and the police?
除了政府和警察之外？
I understood why someone could suspect the police. I've covered a lot of protests over the years. But the cops in and around Ferguson were notably casual about violence.
我理解为什么有人会怀疑警察。多年来我报道过很多抗议活动。但弗格森及周边地区的警察对暴力明显漫不经心。
I saw an officer point an assault weapon mounted on a tripod at a group of demonstrators that included elderly people and small children. Before another demonstration, one that I didn't cover, one cop texted another, quote, "It's going to be a lot of fun beating the hell out of these shitheads once the sun goes down and nobody can tell us apart." He was later charged with assaulting a protester, who was actually an undercover cop.
我看到一名警察用安装在三脚架上的攻击性武器指向一群抗议者，其中包括老年人和小孩。在另一次抗议之前，我没有报道过的那次，一个警察给另一个警察发短信，引用说，“一旦太阳下山，没人能分辨我们是谁，揍扁这些混蛋会很有趣。”他后来被指控袭击了一名抗议者，而那名抗议者实际上是一名卧底警察。
When This American Life reached out to the St. Louis County Police Department for comment, the spokesman emailed back saying that there were roughly 52 police departments in the St. Louis area, which employ about 2,700 officers, essentially saying that you can't categorize all of them the same way. And he said the officer with the assault weapon on a tripod was trying to locate an SUV that reportedly had several assault weapons in it and that the people in the vehicle were threatening to kill law enforcement.
当《美国生活》联系圣路易斯县警察局征求意见时，发言人回电子邮件说，圣路易斯地区大约有52个警察部门，雇用了大约2700名警察，基本上是说你不能把他们所有人都归为一类。他说那名带着三脚架攻击性武器的警察是在试图定位一辆据报道有几件攻击性武器的SUV，而且车里的人威胁要杀死执法人员。
But there's a broader context to this conversation. When I taught African-American history courses, I'd often begin with a series of questions. What if I told you that a person was killed in front of hundreds of witnesses, but no one raised a finger to stop it or even report it?
但这个对话有更广泛的背景。当我教授非裔美国人历史课程时，我经常以一系列问题开始。如果我告诉你一个人在数百名目击者面前被杀，但没有人伸出手指阻止甚至报告它，你会怎么想？
And what if I told you that crowd viewed the murder as entertainment and packed lunches to watch the spectacle? And what if they ritually cut body parts from the deceased to keep as souvenirs? And that this happened not dozens or hundreds of times, but thousands?
如果我告诉你人群把谋杀当作娱乐，并带着午餐来看这场奇观呢？如果他们仪式性地从死者身上割下身体部位作为纪念品呢？这种情况不是发生几十次或几百次，而是数千次呢？
Each question is like plotting a point on a probability graph. And the likelihood of all of them happening together seems vanishingly small. But all this really happened.
每一个问题都像是在概率图上标记一个点。所有这些一起发生的可能性看起来极其渺小。但这一切真的发生了。
Talking to people in Ferguson, the history of outlandish truths, like the Tuskegee experiment, in which physicians in Alabama failed to treat a group of black men infected with syphilis, essentially to see what would happen, or the FBI's counterintelligence program, which surveilled and harassed black leaders in the 1960s, none of this was ever far from the surface. How do you sift between plausible and paranoid when the past looks like this?
与弗格森的人们交谈时，离奇真相的历史，比如塔斯基吉实验（阿拉巴马州的医生未能治疗一群感染梅毒的黑人男性，本质上是为了看会发生什么），或FBI的反情报项目（在20世纪60年代监视和骚扰黑人领袖），所有这些都离表面不远。当过去看起来像这样时，你如何筛选合理与妄想？
As Ashley Yates told me, it would be ahistorical for her not to think that there's something larger at play, something coordinated. Apart from that history, though, there are much more personal reasons that some people in Ferguson suspect a conspiracy. Those people who believe someone wants to kill them-- they've been regularly getting messages from people who apparently want to kill them.
正如阿什利·耶茨告诉我的，如果她不认为有更大的事情在发生，某种协调一致的事情，那将是反历史的。然而，除了那段历史之外，弗格森的一些人怀疑阴谋还有更私人的原因。那些相信有人想杀死他们的人——他们经常从显然想杀死他们的人那里收到信息。
Everyone I spoke with still receives death threats or some sort of hate-filled communication more than four years after Michael Brown's death. Jerome Jenkins of Cathy's Kitchen showed me a fake ticket someone mailed him offering free passage back to Africa. In 2017, Reverend Darryl Gray, who's been involved in social justice efforts in Ferguson, learned of a suspicious package left on the floor of his locked rental truck. It contained a live 6-foot-long python. There were no arrests made in the case.
在迈克尔·布朗去世四年多后，我交谈过的每个人仍然收到死亡威胁或某种充满仇恨的通讯。凯西厨房的杰罗姆·詹金斯给我看了一张别人寄给他的假票，上面提供免费回非洲的票。2017年，一直参与弗格森社会正义努力的达里尔·格雷牧师，在锁着的租赁卡车地板上发现了一个可疑包裹。里面有一条活的6英尺长的蟒蛇。此案没有逮捕任何人。
I also spoke with an activist named Ohun Ashe about what's been going on. She told me she's always hypervigilant these days moving around in St. Louis. She says the people threatening her are not subtle about it.
我还与一位名叫奥亨·阿什的活动家谈到了正在发生的事情。她告诉我，这些天她在圣路易斯移动时总是高度警惕。她说威胁她的人对此并不含蓄。
I have been told that they want to slit my throat and throw me in the Mississippi River. I have read that one several times, that--
我被告知他们想割断我的喉咙并把我扔进密西西比河。我读过好几次那一条，那——
On social media?
在社交媒体上？
Yes. I have read on social media as well that back in the '60s, they would have just threw us in the Mississippi River by now.
是的。我也在社交媒体上读到，回到60年代，他们早就把我们扔进密西西比河了。
Ohun's a small woman, but stands out in a crowd. She wears her hair in braids that go past her shoulders and shirts with slogans like "black men smile too" and "black girls are the purest form of art."
奥亨是一个瘦小的女人，但在人群中很突出。她留着编到肩下的辫子，穿着印有“黑人也会笑”和“黑人女孩是最纯粹的艺术形式”之类的标语的衬衫。
I've been followed by white vans. I have had letters that said that I was an atrocity to the city, I deserve to be dealt with, that they want to silence me for good. So when you have a list of names of people who are known, and they are dying in this mysterious way, as an activist or as a person that people deem active, you wonder, are you next?
我一直被白色货车跟踪。我收到过信，说我是城市的暴行，我理应被对付，他们想永远让我闭嘴。所以当你有一份已知的人员名单，而且他们正以这种神秘的方式死去，作为一名活动家或被人们视为活跃的人，你就会想，下一个会是我吗？
You wonder, who really is around me? You wonder, am I crazy for thinking that, why is this car parked outside at the same time every day? Or who is this new person that's on the block that I didn't recognize before?
你就会想，谁真的在我身边？你就会想，我因为那样想而疯了吗？为什么这辆车每天在同一时间停在外面？或者街区里那个我之前没认出的新人是谁？
I noticed something else when I started talking to people in Ferguson again. Many of the people I met when I first went there no longer live there. Ashley Yates told me she left St. Louis partly because she needed to heal. And another activist told me she moved to Washington, DC after getting what she took to be credible threats on her life. That sense of alarm is clearly what the people making death threats are after. Whether there's an actual conspiracy or not, there are certainly people who want the activists to believe there's one.
当我再次开始与弗格森的人交谈时，我注意到了另一件事。我刚去那里时遇到的许多人现在已经不在那里住了。阿什利·耶茨告诉我，她离开圣路易斯部分原因是她需要治愈。另一位活动家告诉我，在收到她认为是可靠的死亡威胁后，她搬到了华盛顿特区。这种惊慌的感觉显然是那些发出死亡威胁的人想要的。无论是否有真正的阴谋，肯定有人希望活动家们相信有。
Of all the activists I spoke to about the conspiracy, there was one whose position wasn't ambivalent at all-- a rapper named Tef Poe. When I arrived in Ferguson four years ago, person after person directed me to Tef, saying he was the guy to talk to if I really wanted to understand what was going on there.
在我谈论阴谋的所有活动家中，有一位他的立场一点也不模棱两可——一位名叫特夫·波的饶舌歌手。四年前我到达弗格森时，一个人接一个人把我引向特夫，说如果我真的想了解那里发生了什么，他是该谈话的人。
In the years since Michael Brown's death, he's become a more prominent voice nationally. He's currently a fellow at Harvard University. We did a panel there together. Anyhow, his perspective on the idea of a conspiracy was a little different.
在迈克尔·布朗去世后的几年里，他已成为全国更突出的声音。他目前是哈佛大学的研究员。我们在那里一起参加过小组讨论。总之，他对阴谋概念的看法有点不同。
The conspiracy theory, to me, is some unicorn stuff.
对我来说，阴谋论是一些独角兽一样的东西。
Meaning he doesn't believe it. Bassem, the Palestinian activist who died on the bus, had formerly been Tef's roommate. And Danye Jones, who was found hanging in his backyard, was Tef's cousin. He knew Darren Seals, one of the activists shot in a car, just not through activist circles.
意味着他不相信。死在公共汽车上的巴勒斯坦活动家巴塞姆曾是特夫的室友。而死在后院的丹耶·琼斯是特夫的表弟。他认识在车中被枪杀的活动家之一达伦·西尔斯，只是不是通过活动圈子。
--we never know what could happen.
——我们永远不知道会发生什么。
That soft clinking you might hear as he's talking-- Tef wears a necklace with three charms that spell out the name "Allah" in Arabic.
他在说话时你可能会听到的那种轻微的叮当声——特夫戴着一条项链，上面有三个用阿拉伯语拼写出“真主”名字的饰物。
So I can't connect what happened to Seals with what happened to Bassem. I can't connect what happened to Danye with what happened to Bassem. I have to look at each situation for what it is.
所以我无法将发生在西尔斯身上的事与发生在巴塞姆身上的事联系起来。我无法将发生在丹耶身上的事与发生在巴塞姆身上的事联系起来。我必须看待每一种情况的本质。
And somebody like Darren wasn't an activist. He was-- I would consider him a street revolutionary. So his constituency is a lot deeper than just folks who are going to go to the next rally. We're talking about from rival rappers to people who didn't like-- don't like the fact that he survived his original shooting and so forth.
像达伦这样的人不是活动家。他——我会把他视为街头革命者。所以他的选民群体不仅仅是那些要去参加下一次集会的人。我们谈论的是从敌对饶舌歌手到不喜欢他——不喜欢他从最初的枪击中幸存下来等等的人。
And so he'd been shot prior to the time that was fatal.
所以他在致命的那次之前就被枪击过。
Yeah, and he survived. Yeah, yeah.
是的，他幸存下来了。是的，是的。
That shooting had nothing to do with the protests or Michael Brown. It was street stuff.
那次枪击与抗议或迈克尔·布朗无关。那是街头的事。
We live in a city where guns are everywhere. Violence is at large in our city. And I think a lot of people that seek to add a conspiracy to it aren't really living in the circumstances where they have to see the violence and interact with the violence. So they have to create a Puff the Magic Dragon theory about what happened.
我们生活在一个枪支无处不在的城市。暴力在我们的城市蔓延。我认为许多试图在其中增加一个阴谋的人并没有真正生活在那种他们必须看到暴力并与暴力互动的情况中。所以他们必须创造一个关于发生了什么的“普夫龙”理论。
And is that really true, though? I mean, from the very point of, like, Ferguson, or St. Louis, or Chicago, Gary, Philadelphia, New York, any of the cities we talk about, nobody who lives in a black community is really isolated from violence. It's one of those things that can happen to anyone, anywhere.
但那真的是真的吗？我的意思是，从弗格森、圣路易斯、芝加哥、加里、费城、纽约的任何一点来看，任何生活在黑人社区的人都不会真正与暴力隔绝。这是任何地方、任何人都可能发生的事情之一。
That's true. That's true. And I do agree with that. But while it does affect everyone, all of us don't have the same experience.
那是真的。那是真的。我确实同意这一点。但虽然它确实影响每个人，但我们并不是所有人都有同样的经历。
Mm-hm.
嗯哼。
I'm talking about the reality of the stone-cold streets. And a lot of the individuals-- for example, my friend, Bassem, who I loved dearly, a brother of mine-- I helped bury him when he passed away. I know-- and I can say this because Bass is like blood to me-- we refuse to attach a conspiracy theory narrative to Bassem's death.
我说的是冷酷街头的现实。而且许多个人——例如，我深爱的朋友巴塞姆，我的兄弟——他去世时我帮他安葬。我知道——我可以这么说，因为巴斯对我来说就像血亲——我们拒绝给巴塞姆的死贴上阴谋论叙事。
When he passed away, people said, well, what happened? Well, what happened was, he was still in the ghetto. Like, this is the reality of the circumstances. And I'm pissed off about the fact that I keep having to bury people. And people are acting like Santa Claus is coming down here killing folks.
他去世时，人们说，好吧，发生了什么？好吧，发生的是，他仍然生活在贫民窟。就像，这就是情况的现实。我很生气，因为我不得不不断埋葬人们。人们表现得好像圣诞老人到这里来杀人一样。
So like, if I walked outside the studio right now, and somebody shoots me, it's going to be all over the internet. Another Ferguson activist killed, another da-da-da-da-da, avoiding the fact that I come from a family of gangbangers, avoiding the fact that prior to this, I had some enemies.
所以，如果我现在走出工作室，有人开枪打我，那会在互联网上到处都是。又一个弗格森活动家被杀，又一个达达达达达，避免了我来自一个帮派成员家庭的事实，避免了在此之前我有一些敌人的事实。
And you mean enemies who are not connected to your work as an activist.
你的意思是那些与你作为活动家的工作无关的敌人。
As an activist, yeah, yeah.
作为活动家，是的，是的。
It didn't surprise me when Tef pointed out that he keeps a firearm nearby when he's back home. Missouri is an open carry state. I also asked him about the militia group who stood on the roofs with guns during the protests. I wondered what Tef thought about the idea that they might be involved in the conspiracy. He laughed at that. They had their guns, he said. But so did a lot of his friends.
当特夫指出他回到家附近时会随身携带枪支时，我并不感到惊讶。密苏里州是一个公开携带武器的州。我还问他关于抗议期间站在屋顶上拿着枪的民兵组织。我想知道特夫对他们可能参与阴谋的想法怎么看。他对此大笑。他们有他们的枪，他说。但他朋友也有。
And that's where I'm going with this. This is not a city of sitting ducks, where, like-- like, if this was going down, like, the conspiracy aspect of this was really, truly a thing on that level, I just believe that a lot of us would be rocking out a hell of a lot different, man.
这就是我要表达的意思。这不是一个待宰羔羊的城市，在那里，就像——如果这是真的，如果这方面的阴谋论在那个层面上是真正存在的，我只是相信我们中的许多人会有完全不同的行动方式，伙计。
Mm-hm, mm-hm.
嗯哼，嗯哼。
I mean, y'all saw Ferguson, man. I mean--
我的意思是，你们都看到了弗格森，伙计。我的意思是——
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
They don't have to send a firing squad into the apartment to kill you. Now, all they gotta do is leave you in North St. Louis to die. And that serves the same purpose. You're silenced and ostracized from the rest of the world. You're shadow banned on Twitter.
他们不必派行刑队到公寓里来杀你。现在，他们所要做的就是把你留在北圣路易斯等死。而这达到了同样的目的。你被噤声并被世界其他地方排斥。你在推特上被影子封禁。
And you're still there with the killers, thieves, dealers, and the rapists, and the murderers. And the odds are that you will be a victim of that same fate. I mean, for me, that is where the conspiracy comes into play here. It's not with the boogie man that's going to get me when I leave from this interview.
你仍然和杀手、小偷、毒贩、强奸犯和谋杀犯在一起。而且很有可能你会成为同样命运的受害者。我的意思是，对我来说，这就是阴谋发挥作用的地方。它不是那个在我离开这次采访时要来抓我的怪物。
This brings me back to something that had begun rattling around in my mind when I first started talking to people in Ferguson again. What do we actually mean by the word "conspiracy"? Need it be hatched in a dark room hazy with cigar smoke? Or can it be the slow accretion of small decisions, each of which makes life a little bit more difficult, a little bit more dangerous, and opportunities that much more scarce?
这让我想起了当我再次开始与弗格森的人们交谈时在我脑海中回荡的事情。我们说的“阴谋”这个词到底是什么意思？它非得在充满雪茄烟雾的暗室里策划吗？还是它可以是小决定的缓慢积累，每一个都让生活变得更困难、更危险，机会更少？
The problems Tef talked about exist to some degree or another in thousands of communities across the country, most of them far from the site of protests about an unarmed black 18-year-old fatally shot by a white police officer. Conspiracy theories typically explain actions that have been taken. But what kinds of theories explain the failure to act?
特夫谈到的问题在全国成千上万的社区中或多或少地存在，其中大多数远非那起白人警察致命枪杀一名黑人18岁少年的抗议地点。阴谋论通常解释已经采取的行动。但什么样的理论能解释不采取行动的失败？
Those are the questions that the skeptical journalist in me raises. The numbers fluctuate. But maybe 70% of me dismisses the idea of the deaths being orchestrated by a single individual or group. But there's another part of me, the 30% part, that remembers when I first went to Ferguson and thought, I have no idea what the people on the other side of these protests are capable of.
那是作为怀疑论记者的我提出的问题。数字在波动。但也许70%的我排除了死亡事件是由个人或团体精心策划的想法。但我的另一部分，那30%，记得当我第一次去弗格森时想过，我对这些抗议对立面的人们能做什么一无所知。
Skepticism is fundamental to journalism. But it only works if you can recognize the times when you need to be skeptical of your skepticism, too.
怀疑是新闻业的基础。但它只有在你意识到什么时候也需要怀疑你的怀疑时才有效。
Jelani Cobb-- he's a staff writer for the New Yorker magazine. Coming up, a guy who believes in conspiracies follows him closely and then decides to sign up. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
杰拉尼·科布——他是《纽约客》杂志的特约撰稿人。接下来，一个相信阴谋论的家伙紧随其后，然后决定签约加入。那将在来自芝加哥公共广播电台的一分钟后，我们的节目继续进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Anything Can Be Anything." In this very conspiracy-minded moment in our country, where even the President of the United States is spreading conspiracy theories, like, all the time, we have stories of people who see the dots and can't help but connect the dots and then have to figure out what to do with their conclusions. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two-- The Red Menace Hits the Crimson Tide.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“任何事物都可以是任何事物”。在我们国家这个非常倾向于阴谋论的时刻，连美国总统都在一直散布阴谋论，我们有一些人看到这些点，不禁连接这些点，然后必须找出如何处理他们的结论的故事。我们已经到达了我们节目的第二幕。第二幕——红色威胁袭击红色浪潮。
So now, we turn to a guy who is upset about the conspiracies to tamper with the US elections in 2016, the stuff the Russians did. He was outraged about that. But he had a strange way of dealing with it. He decided, I'm going to try that myself in a big political race in 2017 and one of the reddest states in the country, Alabama. Ben Calhoun tells us what happened.
现在，我们要转向一个对2016年篡改美国选举的阴谋感到不安的家伙，那些俄罗斯人做的事情。他对此感到愤慨。但他处理这件事的方式很奇怪。他决定，我要在2017年美国最红的州之一，阿拉巴马州，在一场重大的政治竞选中尝试一下。本·卡尔霍恩告诉我们发生了什么。
I met up with Matt Osborne outside his parents' house in a place called Florence, Alabama. It's this beautiful little city in the northern part of the state.
我在阿拉巴马州佛罗伦萨的一处房子外见到了马特·奥斯本。那是该州北部的一个美丽的小城市。
Now, this street that my folks live on--
现在，这条我父母住的街道——
It was on this street, Matt told me, 2017, he steps out of his parents' house. He looked one way, looked the other. Whoa.
马特告诉我，就是在2017年，他走出他父母的房子。他看了一眼这边，看了一眼那边。哇。
Every house up the street to the corner had a Doug Jones sign.
街上到拐角处的每一所房子都有道格·琼斯的标志。
At the time, remember, Doug Jones was a Democratic candidate for US Senate in Alabama. Matt was seeing Jones lawn signs up and down his parents' street, where usually, Matt says, people have signs for Republicans.
当时，请记住，道格·琼斯是阿拉巴马州美国参议院的民主党候选人。马特看到他父母的街上到处都是琼斯的草坪标志，通常马特说，人们有共和党的标志。
Folks who would ordinarily have been attracted to voting for a conservative, who were willing to vote for Doug Jones, are enthusiastic about voting for Doug Jones. And that told me it was possible for him to win.
那些本来会被吸引去投票给保守派的人，如果愿意投票给道格·琼斯，他们对投票给道格·琼斯是热情的。这告诉我他有可能获胜。
Were you-- were you expecting that at all?
你——你根本没想到这一点吗？
I was floored by it, to be quite frank. I had never seen anything like that for a Democrat, not since I was a kid, not since George Wallace's last run for governor.
老实说，我被震撼了。我从未见过民主党有这样的事情，自从我小时候，自从乔治·华莱士最后一次竞选州长以来。
If you're a Democrat, you know you're in trouble when the last big success story you can remember is the man who said, "Segregation now, segregation tomorrow, segregation forever." But so back to all these Jones lawn signs. Matt was excited, because Matt was a bitter and disaffected Democrat in one of the reddest parts of one of the reddest states.
如果你是民主党人，当你能记住的最后一个成功故事是那个说“现在隔离，明天隔离，永远隔离”的人时，你就知道你有麻烦了。回到所有这些琼斯的草坪标志上。马特很兴奋，因为马特是一个愤怒且心怀不满的民主党人，身处最红的州中最红的地区之一。
2016 sent a lot of Democrats over the edge, of course. And Matt was among them. Matt obviously knew Trump would win Alabama. But he'd gotten pretty obsessed with the dirty tricks he saw online during that election.
2016年当然让很多民主党人陷入了绝境。马特就是其中之一。马特显然知道特朗普会赢得阿拉巴马州。但他对在那次选举中在网上看到的肮脏伎俩变得非常痴迷。
In the 2000s, he'd started writing about shady political tactics he'd spotted on the internet. He wrote about that for sites like Huff Post and Crooks and Liars. Matt actually has an investigator's background-- five years in radio intelligence with the army, after that, a few years as a private eye.
在2000年代，他开始撰写他在互联网上发现的阴暗政治策略。他为《赫芬顿邮报》和《骗子与说谎者》等网站写过相关文章。马特实际上有调查背景——在陆军从事无线电情报工作五年，之后几年作为私家侦探。
Matt was onto some stuff kind of early. Like, he was talking about Twitter bots as early as 2010, writing about Cambridge Analytica two years before most of us had heard of it. So Matt was paying close attention in the 2016 election when he started seeing what he thought were shifty tactics being deployed to help Donald Trump-- accounts that look fake on Twitter and Facebook, doing things like stoking divisions between Sanders Democrats and Clinton Democrats.
马特很早就发现了一些东西。比如，他早在2010年就开始谈论推特机器人，在我们大多数人听说剑桥分析公司之前的两年就开始写关于它的文章了。所以马特在2016年选举中密切关注，当时他开始看到他认为是用来帮助唐纳德·特朗普的狡猾策略——推特和脸书上看起来虚假的账户，做着像煽动桑德斯民主党人和克林顿民主党人之间分歧之类的事情。
And like, how did you see that?
那么，你是怎么看到这一点的？
You know, if you get into a rabid debate with somebody who's just, you know, Bernie, Bernie, I'll never vote for Hillary, you know, start looking at their profile. And you say, that-- that doesn't look right.
你知道，如果你和一个只是“伯尼，伯尼，我永远不会投票给希拉里”的人陷入疯狂的辩论，你知道，开始查看他们的个人资料。你会说，那——那看起来不对。
This Twitter handle doesn't look right, because it's got 12 random numbers in it. So it seems like a computer-generated account. Or this person looks weird, because they've tweeted 1,000 times, but they haven't put up a profile picture. That was a lot of it. Who is this weird profile? Who are the administrators of this suspicious Facebook page?
这个推特账号看起来不对，因为它有12个随机数字。所以看起来像是一个计算机生成的账户。或者这个人看起来很奇怪，因为他们发了1000次推文，但他们没有放个人资料图片。这占了很大一部分。这个奇怪的个人资料是谁？这个可疑脸书页面的管理员是谁？
Who are the admins of this mysterious page that's got all this anti-Hillary Clinton propaganda? Click on the Admin. So I'm looking at a profile now that is striking me right away as fake. All right, it's got 25 friends, who appear to be real people. And none of them are related to each other.
拥有所有这些反希拉里·克林顿宣传的神秘页面管理员是谁？点击管理员。所以我现在正在查看一个让我立刻觉得是假冒的个人资料。好的，它有25个朋友，看起来是真实的人。他们彼此没有任何关系。
When you were having that experience, what was the feeling that you had? Like, outrage, anger? Was it irritation? Was it worry?
当你经历那种体验时，你有什么感觉？比如，愤慨、愤怒？是恼火？还是担心？
Deep foreboding. Deep foreboding, deep foreboding. And the closer we got to the election, the more I felt like something was wrong.
深深的不祥预感。深深的不祥预感，深深的不祥预感。而且我们离选举越近，我就越觉得有什么地方不对劲。
We've all heard about what was wrong now. It's confirmed-- the Russian meddling and propaganda, phony accounts designed to sow divisions among Americans and demoralize voters. Matt had had it. For him, from what I can tell, 2016 was like a tipping point of bitterness.
我们现在都已经听说有什么地方不对劲了。这已被证实——俄罗斯的干预和宣传，旨在在不同美国人之间播下分歧和挫伤选民积极性的虚假账户。马特受够了。对他来说，据我所知，2016年就像一个苦涩的临界点。
Matt's bitterness had been piling up for years. Like, he remembers kids in grade school talking about how they were for the Confederacy, which Matt could not understand.
马特的苦涩多年来一直在堆积。比如，他记得小学时的孩子们谈论他们如何支持邦联，马特无法理解这一点。
And I'll never forget the kid next to me who was talking the most about it. When I saw him again, when I got out of the Army in 1999, and I came home, I ran into him at Walmart. And in the first 60 seconds of our conversation, he was telling me how much he hated immigrants. So I guess maybe part of my problem is that my values have always contradicted the place where I was.
我永远不会忘记旁边谈论最多那个孩子。当我在1999年退伍回家再次见到他时，我在沃尔玛遇到了他。在我们谈话的前60秒内，他就在告诉我他有多么讨厌移民。所以我猜也许我的问题的一部分是我的价值观一直与我所处的地方相矛盾。
So imagine Matt after he left the Army with an injury. He's on partial disability, in chronic pain, searching for direction, spending a lot of time reading the internet and writing about Democratic politics. He's like a blue dot in a red ocean.
所以想象一下马特在受伤离开军队后。他处于部分残疾状态，忍受慢性疼痛，寻找方向，花大量时间阅读互联网并撰写关于民主党政治的文章。他就像红海中的一个蓝点。
Matt describes the last 10 years of his life as him being "radicalized." That was his word. And that is where Matt's head was when Alabama's 2017 Senate election suddenly burst into the center ring of American politics.
马特将他过去10年的生活描述为他被“激进化”了。那是他的话。这就是当阿拉巴马州2017年参议院选举突然爆发出现在美国政治中心舞台时马特的想法。
We begin tonight with the Alabama Senate race, where--
我们今晚从阿拉巴马州的参议院竞选开始，在那里——
Quick refresher. You'll probably remember this. This was a special election to fill the Senate seat vacated by Jeff Sessions, who'd left to be attorney general. On one side, the Democrat, Doug Jones, an uncle-ish looking former prosecutor, and his opponent, Republican Roy Moore, a Bible-quoting former Chief Justice of the Alabama Supreme Court.
快速回顾一下。你可能还记得。这是一场特别选举，以填补杰夫·塞申斯空出的参议院席位，他已离任去担任司法部长。一边是民主党人道格·琼斯，一位看起来像大叔的前检察官，另一边是共和党人罗伊·摩尔，一位引用圣经的前阿拉巴马州最高法院首席大法官。
The race was not supposed to be competitive, until it was. Remember, nine women came forward to accuse Roy Moore of a combination of sexual misconduct and molestation for things he allegedly did when they were young, some underage, as young as 14. Moore denied those allegations. But there was lots of reporting, including accounts of how Moore was allegedly such a creep, he got banned from the local mall.
这场竞选本不应该具有竞争力，直到它变成了这样。记住，九名女性站出来指控罗伊·摩尔在她们年轻时（有些未成年，甚至小到14岁）对他做过一系列性骚扰和猥亵行为。摩尔否认了这些指控。但有很多报道，包括关于摩尔据称是个多么令人毛骨悚然的人的描述，他被当地商场禁止进入。
It wasn't enough to knock Moore out of contention, though. Alabama is just so red that people were saying things like this on conservative talk radio in Birmingham.
但这不足以把摩尔踢出竞争。阿拉巴马州太红了，以至于人们在伯明翰的保守派广播节目中说出这样的话。
What we're getting is, Alabamians would vote for a pedophile over a liberal Democrat.
我们得到的是，阿拉巴马人宁愿投票给一个恋童癖，也不愿投票给一个自由派民主党人。
In this circumstance, yes.
在这种情况下，是的。
OK. You're just saying it flat out, then.
好的。那么你只是直接说了。
Yep, absolutely.
是的，绝对。
It got uglier and uglier. As the allegations against Moore piled up, Breitbart dispatched two reporters with the mission of discrediting the women making the allegations. It turned into a morass of character attacks and aspersions, including fake news stories targeting Moore's accusers.
它变得越来越难看了。随着针对摩尔的指控堆积如山，布赖特巴特新闻派遣了两名记者，任务是抹黑那些提出指控的女性。它演变成了一场性格攻击和诽谤的泥潭，包括针对摩尔指控者的假新闻故事。
And a disaffected, angry Matt Osborne, still stewing over 2016, wanted in super badly, which is how Matt went from despising the sleazy online tactics of 2016, utterly opposing them, to using them for his side. And the moment that tipped him from one side to the other-- it happened on the phone. September-- this was two months before the election-- Matt was talking to a DC political operative he knows. The plan was just, let's brainstorm a bunch of ideas, anything to help Doug Jones.
而一个心怀不满、愤怒的马特·奥斯本，还在为2016年耿耿于怀，非常想参与进来，这就是马特如何从鄙视2016年卑劣的网络战术、彻底反对它们，转变为为自己这一方使用它们。让他从这一边转向那一边的那一刻——发生在电话里。9月——那是选举前两个月——马特正在和一位他认识的华盛顿特区政治顾问通话。计划只是，让我们集思广益出一堆想法，任何能帮助道格·琼斯的事情。
We are talking on the phone. And it's sort of a blue sky discussion.
我们在电话里谈话。这是一种“异想天开”的讨论。
So the two of them start throwing stuff out, from regular ideas to pretty far-out ideas, the kind that start with, what if?
于是他们两人开始抛出各种想法，从普通的想法到相当遥远的想法，那种以“如果……会怎样？”开头的想法。
What if, on election day, you had events in neighboring states that might draw some people from Alabama? Like, you could advertise heavily in Alabama to draw potential Roy Moore voters out of the state on election day.
如果选举日当天，你在邻近州举行活动可能会吸引一些阿拉巴马人离开呢？比如，你可以在阿拉巴马州大力宣传，在选举日当天把潜在的罗伊·摩尔选民吸引出州。
So those are the kind of ideas that are getting kicked around.
所以这些就是被踢来踢去的想法。
Right. These are just crazy ideas getting kicked around.
对。这些只是被踢来踢去的疯狂想法。
And then, suddenly, Matt says, he's throwing out an idea that he hadn't even considered before the moment it was coming out of his mouth. He tells the person on the phone, Alabama Republicans, like both national parties, they're split, right? Internally divided.
然后，突然，马特说，他提出了一个在他脱口而出之前甚至没考虑过的想法。他告诉电话那头的人，阿拉巴马州的共和党人，像两个主要政党一样，他们分裂了，对吧？内部不和。
You've got a more centrist wing. And you've got a more radical wing. So what if, Matt hypothesized, what if we could pose as Republicans online with fake identities, and we could do things to aggravate that divide, make Alabama Republicans feel icky about each other, and try to suppress Republican votes?
你有一个更中间派的派别。你有一个更激进的派别。所以如果，马特假设，如果我们可以假扮成共和党人在网上使用虚假身份，我们可以做一些事情来加剧这种分裂，让阿拉巴马州的共和党人对彼此感到恶心，并尝试压制共和党的选票，那会怎样？
In other words, Matt proposed a conspiracy-- the kind of conspiracy Russians are accused of running in 2016, right? Put out misinformation and disinformation under phony identities to stoke divisions among your opponents. You've probably heard of these referred to as false flag operations.
换句话说，马特提议了一个阴谋——俄罗斯人在2016年被指控运行的那种阴谋，对吧？在虚假身份下发布错误信息和虚假信息，以煽动对手之间的分歧。你可能听说过这些被称为“虚假旗帜”行动。
And that's the one that people want to know about. Like, why don't you write that up and share it with me? So I wrote a little paper.
这就是人们想知道的那一个。比如，你为什么不把它写下来并分享给我？所以我写了一份小论文。
Matt then transformed his rough idea into a detailed plan. He drafted a memo, one this operative could take to Democratic donors to see if anyone might fund it. Matt's idea to divide Alabama Republicans was to divide the religious right Republicans from the more moderate Republicans.
马特随后将他粗略的想法转化为详细的计划。他起草了一份备忘录，一份可以让那位顾问拿给民主党捐款人看，看是否有人可能资助它的备忘录。马特分化阿拉巴马州共和党人的想法是将宗教右翼共和党人与更温和的共和党人分化开来。
Roy Moore had always been closely tied to the extra-religious, conservative wing of his party. In fact, his political operation depended heavily on Alabama's extensive network of Baptist pastors.
罗伊·摩尔一直与他党内极度宗教、保守的派别密切相关。事实上，他的政治运作在很大程度上依赖于阿拉巴马州庞大的浸信会牧师网络。
That pastor network is the backbone of his get-out-the-vote machine. On Wednesday nights, Sundays, that's when the Roy Moore pastors push their flock to go vote for Roy Moore. That's how it works down here.
那个牧师网络是他拉票机器的支柱。周三晚上、周日，那是罗伊·摩尔的牧师们推动他们的羊群去投票给罗伊·摩尔的时候。这就是它在这里运作的方式。
Baptists, as Matt wrote, are the largest denomination in the state, over 40% of the population. But--
浸信会，正如马特写的，是该州最大的教派，占人口的40%以上。但是——
Although Baptists are the largest single denomination in Alabama, they are by no means a majority, all right? So what they are is a very vocal minority.
虽然浸信会是阿拉巴马州单一最大的教派，但他们绝不是多数，好的？所以他们是非常直言不讳的少数。
And, Matt wrote in his memo, the wedge issue to split the Baptists from the more moderate Republicans-- prohibition. I know. You're like, prohibition? Against alcohol? Didn't we settle that like 100 years ago?
而且，马特在他的备忘录中写道，将浸信会与更温和的共和党人分开的楔子问题——禁酒。我知道。你会说，禁酒？反对酒精？我们不是在100年前就解决那个了吗？
But hang on, because Alabama actually has a long history of restrictive alcohol laws. Like, of the 30 counties that make up the northern half of Alabama, 19 counties are dry. Roy Moore's Baptist allies have been all, heck yeah, keep it that way. Get behind me, Satan, to which mainstream Republicans have responded, um, no. Matt says, suburban and business-wing-type Republicans have often favored looser alcohol laws.
但请等一下，因为阿拉巴马州实际上有很长的限制性酒类法律历史。比如，构成阿拉巴马州北部的30个县中，19个县是禁酒的。罗伊·摩尔的浸信会盟友一直都说，该死，保持那样。退到我身后，撒旦，对此主流共和党人回应说，嗯，不。马特说，郊区和商业派的共和党人经常偏向宽松的酒类法律。
The business wing of the Republican Party in Alabama was never enthusiastic about Roy Moore in the first place, all right? If you can get the sort of business-wing Republicans, if you can get the suburban Republican who votes Republican, but he likes to drink his beer on Saturdays while he's watching the football game-- if you can get him to identify Roy Moore with prohibition and moralistic screed-type activity, then they will be less likely to vote for him.
阿拉巴马州共和党的商业派本来就不热衷于罗伊·摩尔，好的？如果你能让那种商业派共和党人，如果你能让那个投票给共和党但喜欢在周六看橄榄球比赛时喝啤酒的郊区共和党人——如果你能让他把罗伊·摩尔与禁酒和道德主义的说教活动联系起来，那么他们投票给他的可能性就会降低。
What we want is for people to say, gosh, Roy Moore is nuts. Roy Moore's followers are nuts, you know? These people who are in my party-- you know, I share a party with them, but they're nuts.
我们想要的是让人们说，天哪，罗伊·摩尔是个疯子。罗伊·摩尔的追随者是疯子，你知道吗？这些人，他们和我是一个党派——你知道，我与他们同属一个党派，但他们是疯子。
There's one more thing to just feel a little less excited about.
还有一件事让你觉得不那么兴奋。
Exactly.
正是如此。
And exactly what the Russians purportedly did to Democrats in 2016-- stoke their internal divisions to make them feel less motivated. Matt's version of that was to create fake groups on social media. One would be named The Southern Caller. The other, Dry Alabama. They'd act like prohibitionist cultural conservatives, enthusiastic about Roy Moore, and hope that they could bum out mainstream Republicans.
而且这正是俄罗斯人在2016年被认为对民主党人所做的——煽动他们的内部分歧，使他们感到不那么有动力。马特的版本是在社交媒体上创建虚假团体。一个叫“南方召唤者”。另一个叫“干燥的阿拉巴马”。他们会表现得像禁酒的文化保守派，对罗伊·摩尔充满热情，并希望他们能让主流共和党人感到沮丧。
You can mirror the activity of 2016 in this sense. All the Russian activity, you can mirror it if you get Republicans arguing with each other. The more they argue with each other, and the more Republicans see other Republicans arguing with each other, the less likely they are to vote.
在这个意义上，你可以镜像2016年的活动。所有的俄罗斯活动，如果你让共和党人互相争吵，你就可以镜像它。他们互相争吵得越多，共和党人看到其他共和党人互相争吵得越多，他们投票的可能性就越小。
When you pitched the idea of Dry Alabama, was there any part of you that had any apprehensions about sort of deploying that kind of strategy?
当你提出“干燥的阿拉巴马”想法时，你是否有任何对部署那种策略的担忧？
You know, by that time, I had already made up my mind. Like, I'm ready to pull out all the stops. I had made up my mind already that I was willing to create content under a false flag, if you will. I was willing to trick Republicans into not voting. That was fine with me.
你知道，到那时，我已经下定决心了。就像，我准备好竭尽全力了。我已经下定决心，如果可以的话，我愿意在虚假旗帜下创造内容。我愿意诱骗共和党人不投票。那对我来说没问题。
Matt says, when he sent off his memo, he wasn't sure if people would want to fund his plan. He was, after all, in the party that had been waving around Michelle Obama's slogan-- when they go low, we go high-- and using that to attack Republicans. And for a while, Matt heard nothing-- for weeks-- so long that he figured no one wanted to fund his dirty tricks.
马特说，当他发出他的备忘录时，他不确定人们是否会想要资助他的计划。毕竟，他身处的政党一直挥舞着米歇尔·奥巴马的口号——当他们走低时，我们走高——并用它来攻击共和党人。有那么一段时间，马特没有听到任何消息——数周——长到他以为没人想资助他的肮脏伎俩。
I was sitting in my living room. What was I watching? I don't remember. I was watching TV. And my phone rang. And I'm told, hey, we got money.
我坐在客厅里。我在看什么？我不记得了。我在看电视。电话响了。我被告知，嘿，我们弄到钱了。
It was the Democratic operative in DC. "We got money" meant some donors had decided to fund Matt's proposal. Matt's reaction?
是华盛顿特区的民主党顾问。“我们弄到钱了”意味着一些捐款人已经决定资助马特的提议。马特的反应？
Bam.
砰。
No kidding. This is for real?
别开玩笑了。这是真的吗？
Oh, wow. This is real. This is-- this is happening. OK, cool.
哦，哇。这是真的。这是——这正在发生。好的，酷。
The donors put up $100,000. Part of that would pay for a team of people to create these fake conservative groups. The rest of the money, most of it, would pay for ads on Facebook to shove what they made into the social media feeds of Alabama Republicans.
捐款人拿出了10万美元。部分将支付给一个团队来创建这些虚假保守派团体。其余的钱，大部分，将用于在脸书上投放广告，把他们制作的内容推送到阿拉巴马州共和党人的社交媒体动态中。
At this point, there were only 17 days left before the election. So they had to go fast. Work started immediately-- bogus email addresses, fake logos. The team doing this, I should say-- sort of fascinatingly tiny-- just two people in DC and then Matt in Alabama.
此时，距离选举只剩下17天了。所以他们必须快点。工作立即开始——虚假的电子邮件地址，虚假的标志。做这件事的团队，我应该说——令人着迷的小——只有华盛顿特区的两个人，然后是阿拉巴马州的马特。
One of the people in DC, Matt says, was sort of doing oversight, not even super involved. The other person in DC created tweets and memes. Matt did the Facebook posts and the videos.
马特说，华盛顿特区的一个人算是做监督，甚至没有超级参与。华盛顿特区的另一个人制作推文和表情包。马特做脸书帖子和视频。
The whole group was so small. It kind of makes you realize, you don't need a building full of people to do this kind of thing. It can be a conspiracy of just two or three.
整个团队太小了。这让你意识到，你不需要整栋楼的人来做这种事情。它可能只是两三个人的阴谋。
Matt, as an Alabama native, was kind of the person who the group turned to make the con seem authentic. Hey, Matt, how would people say this in Alabama? How would they say that?
马特作为阿拉巴马本地人，算是那个让骗局看起来真实的人。嘿，马特，人们在阿拉巴马州会怎么说这个？他们会怎么说那个？
Hey, Matt, how do you spell "barbecue" in Alabama? What-- we want to come across as authentic. I said, BBQ, or spell it out, barbecue with a C, right? Alabamian instead of Alabaman, that sort of thing.
嘿，马特，你在阿拉巴马州怎么拼写“barbecue”？什么——我们想表现得真实。我说，BBQ，或者把它拼出来，用C拼写的barbecue，对吧？阿拉巴马人而不是阿拉巴马人，诸如此类。
There were some things that were deemed too much, even by dirty tactic standards. Matt pointed out that something that would inevitably get a ton of engagement would be an AR-15 giveaway. The funder, it turned out, was not OK with a gun giveaway, real or fake. But even if they weren't going to give away an AR-15, there was a lot of room for imagination. Like, Matt recruited a woman he knew.
有些事情被认为是太过分了，即使按照肮脏战术的标准。马特指出，必然会获得大量参与的一件事是AR-15赠送。资助者，结果发现，并不赞成真实的或虚假的枪支赠送。但即使他们不打算赠送AR-15，也有很大的想象空间。比如，马特招募了他认识的一个女人。
I will just-- for our purposes today, I will call her Sharon.
我只是——为了我们今天目的，我会叫她莎伦。
Matt hired Sharon to do a voiceover on a video that he made for Dry Alabama.
马特雇佣莎伦为他制作的“干燥的阿拉巴马”视频做配音。
She's wonderful. She's as Alabama as they come. She has the perfect accent, right? The kind of middle Alabama, kind of rapid-clip accent with all the right vowel inflections.
她很棒。她如假包换的阿拉巴马人。她有完美的口音，对吧？那种阿拉巴马中部的，那种语速很快的口音，带有所有正确的元音发音。
So at the next tailgate party, instead of drinking and succumbing to evil temptation, try thing amazing, Bama-style, alcohol-free cocktail. Try this moral take on a sinful beverage, a righteous mint julep. Place mint leaves in an old-fashioned glass. Pour in lemon juice and sugar. And mix with a spoon until the sugar's completely dissolved.
所以，在下一次尾门派对上，不要喝酒并屈服于邪恶的诱惑，尝试这个惊人的、阿拉巴马风格的、无酒精鸡尾酒。尝试这个对罪恶饮料的道德采取，正义的薄荷朱利酒。将薄荷叶放入古典玻璃杯中。倒入柠檬汁和糖。用勺子搅拌直到糖完全溶解。
This video, just to say, does have the genuine lo-fi feel of those try-this-recipe videos that you see online all the time.
这个视频，我只想说，确实有那些你在网上一直看到的“尝试这个食谱”视频的真实低保真感。
Fill the cup with ice and pour sparkling water over the top. Garnish with a sprig of mint. And you've got some smooth as fine cotton. Pledge your support for a Dry Alabama today. And join our crusade for a Dry Alabama.
在杯子里加满冰，倒上苏打水。用一小枝薄荷装饰。你就有了像细棉布一样光滑的东西。今天就承诺支持一个干燥的阿拉巴马。并加入我们对干燥的阿拉巴马的十字军东征。
At one point, talking about all this, Matt said, some of this feels new. But in his mind, it's actually not, really. If you remember, Matt did radio intelligence in the Army.
在讨论所有这些时，马特说，其中一些感觉很新。但在他看来，实际上并不是真的。如果你记得，马特在军队里做过无线电情报。
He told me, one tactic they teach you is something called spoofing. You find the enemy's radio frequency. And then you mimic the voice of the people on it. And you give out bad information.
他告诉我，他们教给你的一个战术叫做“欺骗”。你找到敌人的无线电频率。然后你模仿上面人们的声音。然后你散布坏信息。
Then, he read a tweet from Dry Alabama. "Be sober, be vigilant, because your adversary, the devil, as a roaring lion walketh about, seeking whom he may devour." That's from First Peter, Matt told me.
然后，他读了一条来自“干燥的阿拉巴马”的推文。“你们要谨守、警惕，因为你们的仇敌魔鬼，如同吼叫的狮子走来走去，寻找可吞吃的人。”那是来自彼得前书，马特告诉我。
Doug Jones comes from behind. And now, CNN projects, he will be the next Senator-- first time in 25 years that a Democrat--
道格·琼斯从落后中追了上来。现在，CNN预计，他将成为下一任参议员——25年来第一次有民主党人——
More than 1.3 million people voted in the election. Doug Jones defeated Roy Moore by just 22,000 votes. Altogether, $51 million was spent on the race, which unleashed a hurricane of TV ads, armies of canvassers, meaning it's just impossible to gauge what effect Matt's thing had.
超过130万人参加了选举。道格·琼斯仅以2.2万票击败了罗伊·摩尔。总共，这场竞选中花费了5100万美元，引发了一场电视广告飓风、拉票大军，这意味着根本不可能衡量马特做的事情有什么效果。
Matt's team considered the project a success, though. On a wrap-up call, he was told, with just $100,000, the team's content was seen 4.6 million times, their videos watched hundreds of thousands of times. Everybody was happy with those numbers. But people also felt like the whole thing was a success in the sense that they'd pulled off the fakery without getting caught. That was part of what they were testing.
不过，马特的团队认为这个项目是成功的。在总结电话中，他被告知，仅用了10万美元，团队的内容被浏览了460万次，视频被观看了数十万次。每个人都对那些数字感到满意。但人们也觉得，整个事情是成功的，因为他们完成了欺诈而没有被抓住。这正是他们测试的一部分。
I'm just going to confess here that I'm somebody who's troubled by the culture of our politics right now. I believe people should feel a societal pressure to win with ideas and inspiration and that playing dirty should be looked down on, because playing dirty, I think, encourages suspicion and cynicism. And that's bad for everybody.
我只是要在这里承认，我是一个对我们现在政治文化感到困扰的人。我相信人们应该感受到一种社会压力，通过理念和灵感去获胜，而玩弄肮脏手段应该被看不起，因为玩弄肮脏，我想，会鼓励怀疑和愤世嫉俗。这对每个人都不好。
Maybe because of that, when I went to see Matt, I half thought that because he spent so much time outraged about this kind of deceptive and scuzzy politics, that maybe, after having some time to think it over, he'd end up with some kind of buyer's remorse. Like, I drank so much. What did I say?
也许因为这样，当我去看马特时，我有一半以为因为他在这种欺骗性和卑劣的政治上花了太多愤怒的时间，也许，在思考之后，他会以某种买方后悔而告终。就像，我喝得太多了。我说过什么？
Doesn't it feel like, especially in-- you know, during the presidency of Donald Trump, that the norms are only the norms if most people adhere to them, you know? Like--
难道你不觉得，特别是在——你知道，在唐纳德·特朗普的总统任期内，规范只有在大多数人遵守它们时才是规范吗，你知道？比如——
Well, what is the norm here? The norm here is that Democrats are supposed to go high and get kicked in the knees. That's the norm. The norm is that Republicans play dirty and win.
嗯，这里的规范是什么？这里的规范是民主党人应该走高并被踢中膝盖。这就是规范。规范是共和党人玩弄肮脏并获胜。
Is that the norm that we're supposed to preserve? Because if that's the norm that we're supposed to preserve, let that norm die, I say. Burn it down. Burn it to the ground.
那是我们应该保留的规范吗？因为如果我们应该保留那个规范，让那个规范死吧，我说。把它烧掉。把它烧成灰烬。
So the core of what I hear you saying is that you don't think that it's something that you can combat by example and just say, we're going to refuse to win that way.
所以我听到你说的核心是你认为这不是一个你可以通过例子来对抗、仅仅说我们拒绝以那种方式获胜的事情。
Oh, look at me. I have clean hands and clean clothes, and I'm standing above you in a shining light, and I don't have any power. I can't actually make any changes. But don't I look good? And isn't that the important thing?
哦，看看我。我有干净的手和干净的衣服，我站在闪耀的光芒中凌驾于你们之上，而且我没有任何权力。我实际上做不出任何改变。但看起来我不够好吗？而且那不是重要的事情吗？
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
It sounds so harsh when you put it that way.
当你那样说时，听起来太刺耳了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I'm not about to referee Matt's idea that Republicans play dirtier. What I do think is important is whether these tactics will continue to spread. Over the last few months, there's been excellent reporting about a number of digital strategies tried out by Democrats in this Alabama race in addition to Matt's.
我不打算裁判马特关于共和党玩弄肮脏的观点。我确实认为重要的是这些战术是否会继续传播。在过去的几个月里，除了马特的之外，关于民主党人在这次阿拉巴马竞选中尝试的许多数字策略有极好的报道。
In one, Democrats created fake Russian bots to make it look like Russians were helping Roy Moore. In another, a company microtargeted voters on social media, sent them messages it claims drove up Democratic turnout by 4% and drove down Republican turnout by over 2%. Senator Doug Jones, I should say, has said he disapproves, knew nothing about this stuff. He's called for an investigation.
其中一个，民主党人制造了虚假的俄罗斯机器人，让人们看起来俄罗斯人在帮助罗伊·摩尔。在另一个中，一家公司在社交媒体上对选民进行了微定向，发送了他们声称使民主党投票率提高了4%并使共和党投票率下降了超过2%的信息。我应该说，道格·琼斯参议员说他反对，对这些事情一无所知。他呼吁进行调查。
From talking to Democratic fundraisers, I can tell you for sure, there's plenty of donors who don't want any part of this kind of thing. But there's definitely a portion, I hear, who say, yeah, it's time. They're ready to throw money at stuff like this.
与民主党募款人交谈，我可以肯定地告诉你，有很多捐款人不想参与这种事情。但肯定有一部分，我听说，他们说，是的，是时候了。他们准备给这样的事情投钱。
Matt says, he thinks, when it comes to these kind of dirty tactics, the situation is going to have to get worse before it gets better, because in our gridlocked system, you won't get regulations against this stuff until both parties are fed up with it, which, that sounds like a real bummer to me. But I have to admit, there's a logic to that.
马特说，他认为，当涉及到这种肮脏战术时，情况在变好之前必须先变糟，因为在我们僵化的系统中，你不会得到针对这种事情的法规，除非双方都对此感到厌倦，这对我来说听起来真的很糟糕。但我必须承认，这有逻辑。
For his part, Matt's not going to stop, at least if someone will pay for him to keep doing things like this. If you want to see the memo that led to his misinformation campaign, you can go read it yourself these days. Matt's posted it on his LinkedIn profile. He wants to get hired to do more stuff just like this.
就他而言，马特不会停止，至少如果有人会付钱让他继续做这样的事情。如果你想看看导致他虚假信息活动的备忘录，你这些天可以自己去读。马特已经把它发布在他的LinkedIn个人资料上了。他想被雇佣做更多这样的事情。
Ben Calhoun is one of the producers of our show.
本·卡尔霍恩是我们节目的制片人之一。
Our program was produced today by Dana Chivvis. The people who put a show together includes Elna Baker, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Jarrett Floyd, Damien Graef, Seth Lind, Lina Misitzis, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Alissa Ship, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们的节目今天由达纳·奇维斯制作。把节目放在一起的人包括埃尔纳·贝克、本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、阿维娃·德科恩费尔德、贾勒特·弗洛伊德、达米安·格拉夫、塞思·林德、莉娜·米西齐斯、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们的主编是大卫·克里斯滕鲍姆。
Special thanks today to Eddie Hedge, Kenneth Anderson, Steve Kolowich, Jesse Walker, Katherine Mangu-Ward, Melissa Ryan, Joe Stokes, Brian McCabe, Sarah Koenig, Joseph Parent, Peter Mondo, Whitney Phillips, the St. Louis County Police Department, the St. Louis Metropolitan Police Department, the St. Louis County Medical Examiner's Office, John Larson at St. Louis Public Radio, and Missouri State Representative Maria Chappelle-Nadal.
今天特别感谢埃迪·赫奇、肯尼斯·安德森、史蒂夫·科洛维奇、杰西·沃克、凯瑟琳·曼古-沃德、梅丽莎·瑞安、乔·斯托克斯、布莱恩·麦凯布、莎拉·柯尼格、约瑟夫·帕伦特、彼得·蒙多、惠特尼·菲利普斯、圣路易斯县警察局、圣路易斯大都会警察局、圣路易斯县法医办公室、圣路易斯公共广播电台的约翰·拉尔森和密苏里州众议员玛丽亚·查佩尔-纳达尔。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Special thanks as always to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he bought an obedience book for his dog. I don't think he knows how to use it. He just basically put the book on the ground next to her and told her--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以绝对免费收听我们超过600集的存档。《美国生活》由公共广播交换PRX交付给公共广播电台。特别感谢一如既往我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他为他的狗买了一本服从书。我不认为他知道怎么使用它。他只是基本上把书放在她旁边的地上，告诉她——
There you go. You read that, girl.
这就对了。你去读读看，姑娘。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来会有更多《美国生活》的故事。